fue una escasa participación según un
recorrido que hizo france24 durante todo
el día desde el oeste hasta el este de
la capital la verdad que hubo muy poca
participación comparado a otras
elecciones también se vio que quienes
acudieron a votar en su mayoría digamos
el casi el total de los que salieron a
votar iban a votar por el partido de
gobierno y sus aliados el consejo
nacional electoral extendió el cierre de
urnas de por una hora más e insistió a
las autoridades y a los miembros de mesa
que no pueden cerrar hasta que no haya
el último votante mientras esto ocurre
el partido del gobierno es digámoslo que
su campaña a la parte de la campaña
electoral está insistiendo por los
medios de comunicación llamando a sus
seguidores que salgan a votar todavía
que tienen tiempo para que hagan lo que
ellos llaman el remate perfecto
herminia ya como lo habíamos dicho los
partidos de la oposición no tuvieron
participación en estos comicios
legislativos prácticamente los
candidatos que hay representan algunas
fuerzas del chavismo unos más cercanos a
nicolás maduró otros no tanto como
estará entonces conformada esta posible
nueva asamblea nacional y pues como será
entonces el escenario político con este
triunfo del chavismo en este órgano
legislativo
si hoy se están eligiendo doscientos
setenta y siete escaños anteriormente
eran 167 son 111 más esto lo decidió el
consejo nacional electoral diciendo que
había crecido la población y que había
que hacerlo los analistas estiman que
por la extensión que se vaya a dar el
día de hoy que calculan que esté por el
70 por ciento el chavismo y sus aliados
se apoderarían de unos 215 escaños lo
cual significaría de estos 177 lo cual
significaría que obtendría una mayoría
absoluta
nicolás maduro llamó a todo su personal
oa todas las personas más cercanas a él
para que se lanzaran a candidatos entre
eso su esposa su hijo también ocho
ministros renunciaron para ir como
candidatos del partido socialista unido
de venezuela también de diputados que
eran de la asamblea nacional
constituyente todo esto en pro de poder
lograr el máximo poder y retomar de
nuevo la asamblea nacional
él venía también lo mencionábamos la
comunidad internacional ya dijo que no
va a reconocer estos comicios organismos
como por ejemplo la unión europea han
sido enfáticos en no reconocer este
proceso por carecer de garantías
democráticas esto entonces en la
práctica en que se traduce qué medidas
pueden verse reflejadas en la práctica y
cuál será el papel entonces que tendrá
juan guaidó que es el presidente de la
asamblea nacional que termina la
legislatura y también es el presidente
de venezuela reconocido por 50 países a
nivel mundial
sí como ya lo dijiste de antemano ya la
unión europea eeuu dijeron que no lo van
a reconocer la unión europea de hecho
pidió que se digamos se suspendieran o
que por lo menos se les fuese hiciera
una fecha más adelantada pero el
gobierno de nicolás maduro no lo aceptó
hoy el ex presidente español rodríguez
zapatero señalaba en los medios de
comunicación venezolanos le decía a la
unión europea y eeuu y el resto de la
comunidad internacional que tenían que
cómo se va a apoyar a estas elecciones y
les decía que era apoyar al pueblo
venezolana esto va a pasar lo mismo que
en el 2018 que la comunidad
internacional no apoyó a nicolás maduro
como presidente y va a pasar lo mismo
con esta asamblea nacional